the President of the United States is
regularly violating the First Amendment
to the Constitution now you might say
David that's your opinion but it's
actually the view of a federal court
which has decided that when Donald Trump
blocks people on Twitter which he does
all the time he is violating the
Constitution's First Amendment this is a
statement from Judge a decision from
Judge Naomi Rice Buckwald who says that
no government official including the
president is above the law and all
government officials are presumed to
follow the law as has been declared we
hold that portions of the real Donald
Trump Twitter account the interactive
space where Twitter users may directly
engage with the content of the
president's tweets are properly analyzed
under the public forum doctrines set
forth by the Supreme Court that such
space is a designated public forum and
that the blocking of the plaintiffs
based on their political speech
constitutes viewpoint discrimination
that violates the First Amendment Donald
Trump according to a court decision
regularly violating the First Amendment
of the United States
now Trump's Justice Department doesn't
agree they have a different view they
say that just because the president is
the president doesn't mean he can't take
advantage of the associational freedoms
of being up being on Twitter which
basically means if you're on Twitter you
get to use the platform the way it's
it's a setup right which includes that
you can mute people and that you can
block people and that you can do
whatever it is you want to do on Twitter
so despite the judge's decision that
Trump is violating the First Amendment
she said she's not going to grant relief
to the defendants and I actually think
there's a really important difference
here between muting and blocking if
Trump mutes you he won't see your
comments to him but you can see what he
tweets if Trump blocks you you can no
longer see his tweets while logged into
your account which legally the point is
is a completely different situation now
I have a couple genuine questions here
number one does this apply to foreign
Twitter users in other words if you are
a citizen of France and you were born in
France you're not an American resident
or citizen and
anyway does this apply can the president
block people from foreign countries
I don't really know maybe it doesn't
matter question number two and I think
this is the most most interesting
question can Donald Trump block bots
accounts can he block Russian BOTS or
whoever would that violate the First
Amendment because those BOTS are being
run by people but they're not really
people in the public forum sense of the
thing I don't know maybe this doesn't
really matter I wonder what the
constitutional originalist point of view
on this would be like what would James
Madison and Thomas Jefferson a
distinction between blocking someone and
muting someone on Twitter
isn't this why I mean okay so like let's
forget about James Madison for a second
but if you're a constitutional
originalist your view would be that the
Constitution as written in the 18th
century and as amended since would
account for such questions as
presidential behavior on social media
platforms like Twitter right that would
be if you're a constitutional
originalist then you must believe that
by definition you would believe that the
Constitution as written accounts for any
future technology or circumstances that
may present themselves if you are not a
constitutional originalist if you're for
example a constitutional pragmatist as I
consider myself this would be yet
another one of the ways in which the
Constitution just does not account for
the ways in which society has changed
since the 18th century and through the
amendment process and I think that that
applies to the First Amendment I think
that applies to the Second Amendment and
there are many other considerations that
are just impossible for the Constitution
to have made but to make the sort of
headline here clear a judge has decided
that the President of the United States
is regularly violating the First
Amendment to the Constitution despite
being the guy whose party is supposedly
all about free speech they are I guess
the free speech warriors so note no
shortage of hypocrisy and double
standards